the show is sponsored by expressvpn stop
putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com yang
[Applause]
one thing that a producer a friend of
yours said that really um
seemed telling was look people come to
us for comfort like they don't see us as
the news
uh i i thought that was incredible and
and there is something fundamental about
uh two different purposes one would be
i'm going to edify and inform and so i'm
going to
serve you some stuff that might be not
that scintillating it might be kind of
boring it's like broccoli as programming
and then there's this other direction
that it's like i'm entertainment
like i'm going to have a certain patter
and rhythm and characters and something
that you can cheer or boo
right yeah and that was in one of our uh
planning meetings so that was a senior
producer and um
it's definitely something that you know
stood out and something i remembered
because
you're abdicating your role as a
journalist and that's it's confusing
because
otherwise it kind of looks like a
newscast you know you have an anchor
sitting at a desk
with you know you know the tv over his
shoulder
and you're covering things that are in
the news that's what i think is really
dangerous when it looks like something
that should be reliable
but it it isn't really then that's
that's
to me where the problem comes in
[Music]
this week on yank speaks we interview
ariana picari who until very recently
was
a producer at msnbc she resigned
publicly saying that
the business model of cable news is
distorting journalism
in a way that is not good for the public
you can imagine why we wanted to talk to
her it's a fascinating conversation for
those of you who wanted to
understand the internal dynamics of
what's happening in various news
organizations
this is the episode for you and ariana
has earned our
respect and admiration for doing
something that very very few other
people have done and that's
actually act on principle uh so
tune in this week but before then zach
and i are going to talk about a whole
lot of stuff
the ongoing drama the election
coronavirus you name it andrew
real question man what's going on
in the world i'm i'm trying to i want i
want you i think there's a good way to
start the episode
our listeners out there there's no
source of truth
there's news coming left and right
saying the election's fake
it's not this we've got coronavirus all
over the place
um we got a georgia runoff no one knows
anything
for the average human i feel for them
because there's just so much
noise out there so what is go let's
start with the election andrew
please make sense of this for me for
anybody listening what's going on
it is very painful zach the republicans
have identified a strategy that's
actually working for them politically
even though it's not going to change
anything
in the end but it's changing a lot in
the interim in a very painful way
where i saw something and said 50 of
republicans don't think this election
was fair
and they've been leveling accusations
that have been completely baseless and
groundless and have no legal foundation
they just bring lawsuits
they get tossed out you know in a lot of
these environments
there were republicans who were
definitely in the room counting votes
but also in some cases running the whole
process and they're looking up saying
like why why are you
accusing me of a fraud i mean there was
a recount
in georgia just confirmed it that
georgia went for joe so
uh so this is a loser legally it's a
loser on jan 20 when joe
uh becomes the new rightful occupant of
the white house
but it turns out and this is bad for all
of us it's a winner politically
it's a winner that there are all of
these
republican voters who are very
passionate about
the fact that trump somehow still should
be the president
and that this election was not free and
fair
and that's going to have negative
effects for
years you know it's like if you can't
trust
uh something like a vote count that's
been reported by every media
major media organization uh you know
what what's left
to trust i'm um
here's i thought i would do i would try
to put in some
kind of here's what we know here's
what's happened like factually
um and i want to talk about someone
who's controversial
um tucker carlson um
who for context and tucker he says some
things
and does some things i really disagree
with and do not like at all
but he was really fair to us on the
trail i think he's fair to a lot of
candidates
um and there are times he covers stuff
that no one's touching which
i do respect um so this is what seems to
happen
sydney powell who's one of trump's
attorneys has done a whole bunch of
press
conferences with rudy giuliani right
behind her sweating his
hair dye all over his face or whatever
um
she has claimed that quote communist
money is being
funneled quote communist money end quote
uh is being funneled to venezuela and
cuba to interfere with our elections
and is quoted saying that the voting
software
tracking votes broke because of the
landslide victory
and so many votes coming in for donald
trump that it broke
and which i want to put in context this
is the president united states
lawyer right now has made an accusation
of in my opinion i don't think an
opinion this is the greatest that
if it's true would be the greatest crime
in american history
like literally a stolen election tucker
carlson said
literally that's a major accusation and
he comes out there tucker
far right says i'll let you come on my
show but we have asked you a million
times for evidence and he's gotten
nothing received nothing yeah it's
it uh they they have zero
uh and it's painful watching them
fabricate
various versions of reality and it's
even more painful seeing millions of
americans say yeah yeah yeah
but the fact that trump now is broken
with fox and now
is saying go to newsmax and one america
news network i mean
holy cow i had to look up newsmax i had
to be like
you know like do they have cable
coverage like is this a cable channel is
this all
digital is this like uh it's dark man
and tucker is saying this is if
if there's no proof this is nonsense it
needs a stop and that was my point where
if tucker's doing it guys like wake the
hell up this is just
fake this is literally the mind [ __ ]
part of my french
it's working too that's the tough part
it's working why [ __ ] is working
um mitt romney made a statement finally
it was my opinion took too long he said
having failed to make even a plausible
case of widespread fraud or conspiracy
before any court of law
the president is now resorted to overt
pressure on state and local officials to
subvert the will of the people and
overturn the election and this is the
statement part i love
it is difficult to imagine a worse more
undemocratic action by a sitting
american president
hey zach i just want to say that like
that trump is still winning because
we're still talking about trump even
though we lost
you know what i mean like like we're
falling in a trap just talking about
like mitt talking about trump i mean
like the the concrete impact is
um devastating on two dimensions number
one public trust erodes further
the media landscape splinters further to
even less responsible actors i mean
that's hard to believe
and then number two you have a really
really problematic transition
where you have this government in
waiting that is unfunded
it can't talk to anyone who's in
government
there's a pretty long stretch uh between
beginning of november and late january
you know that's like a solid two and a
half months
and it's it's damaging where
uh you have like a real
uh void or so or
a vacuum or like a period when frankly
no one's running the show
and we've kind of gotten accustomed to
that as a country under the trump
administration but like this is not the
time for that with kovid spiking
so there there's some very very concrete
negative effects of this dynamic for
sure
i appreciate the folks that are trying
to that even see it like mitt romney's
like oh my gosh like this is getting so
bad even i'm gonna like you know
uh like have to to step in and uh try
and
um express fact or reason uh fact
and reason are losing in the united
states and that that's the thing that
um that i think most people are still
struggling with really
like there's like this fundamental
notion that humans are reasonable
which i i tend to believe we're
reasonable a lot of the time um and then
and media
organizations fall into this trap in a
very big way where it's like well i'm
going to now
like present you with fact and reason
i'm very reasonable i'm a journalist or
whatever
and and more and more people are just
saying like i don't care what you say
i don't care what your evidence is i
want to believe this i will believe this
you're an [ __ ] uh you know and
uh and we need to reckon with that in a
different way
it's like the language of fact and
reason will not work on that
you know what i mean like i mean it's
clear that
that uh that trumpism
has now uh transcended a particular
um unified set of facts
uh you know now now it's on in like a
it's in like the land of human nature
uh and the land of human nature uh
operates on reason somewhat
but it also operates on feeling
and emotion and tribalism
and anger and hate and
uh um humanity really
and this is one thing that does make me
um
empathetic in a particular way is that
there is something very dehumanizing to
a lot of our
uh institutional life today you know
what i mean like
you have these folks who are um who are
kind of transformed into
instruments of a bureaucracy or
instruments of a major media
organization
uh and then they're progenitors of this
narrative of reason
say hey be reasonable uh and then if
people are put in circumstances that are
actually
very very unreasonable like let's say
they're
you know towns-only restaurant just
closed because they covet and like
they're losing their job and like their
family life's
going to pieces then reason is not the
right language
you know and trump has managed to tap
into another language
that is working very well on tens of
millions of americans
and the folks who are using the language
of reason just keep looking up saying
like why
like what is going on like at some point
the reasonable thing to do
is to try and uh peer into the realm of
unreasonableness and say okay like
what's going on here
you know that's certainly where i am
well the other reasonable thing to do
is to ignore it um or accept it as
whatever and what i taught my dad
earlier is like you know we had a whole
conversation on politics and he's like
this is so frustrating you want to watch
football you want to go play golf like
literally that's
distract yourself from that that would
be
a respite for us all uh you know and
that's another thing that i dislike
about what's happening here is
we've had a very very uh divisive and
tumultuous four years politically
and unfortunately it looks like it's
just going to continue because trump's
going to
bring the spotlight with them and one
thing we're to talk to ariana about
in part is what the media organization's
incentives are to cover and not cover
trump
so media organizations certainly built
trump up on the way up
and then when he's in the white house in
a way you can't fault them for just
following him around all the time
because he is the president
uh so the question is what now you know
like
and uh if the media networks follow
trump around
post-presidency uh then we're really
going to have like a very legitimate um
beef with them shall we say like a like
that would be the clearest
sign of like hey at this point we just
follow the man around because he rates
and uh and it does not matter if it's
good or bad for
the public it doesn't matter if it's
good or bad for the state of mind
um but the the tough truth is that trump
is just a much more
interesting figure uh than most
politicians you know i mean he's just
like more
like he evokes like a more visceral
reaction either positively or negatively
and right now we have news media that
thrives on trying to evoke
that kind of reaction yeah the news
stopped caring about the well-being of
the country and the people
a long time ago um but it's
um i guess that's what i thought about i
mean that's what this episode is about
many ways
yeah meanwhile like through all this
americans are
suffering and it is horrible 12 million
people
going to lose unemployment benefits by
the end of the year
and it's a good segue to tweet of the
week or you said something that has 300
000 likes at this time right now um
which is one probably your best ever
potentially uh
you said oh no man i've done better than
that i've done better than that [ __ ]
yeah like you look at the tape my bad
well look at the tape
it's up there though um if we
if we ask you to stay home we should
also send you money so you can do so
um which is a very good andrew yang
simple
a cut to the core thoughts on what's
happening with our lack of relief bill
besides that it sucks when you can say
that too but um thoughts on where your
head's at or what you think needs to
happen now
i've gotten a couple of very big
learnings over the last uh number of
weeks and months
uh learning number one is that um
trumpism
is still vital and powerful and rising
because uh institutional mistrust is
vital and powerful and rising and
despite joe's victory
you know we need to reckon with it still
um the fact that
that this was not a blue wave in a lot
of parts of the country is a red wave
and i talked to folks who lost
uh their elections um people like
max rose for example where like you know
like i i expected him to win and
and i think you know most people
expected him to win they didn't
and there were now seven members of
congress uh who
lost their seats that uh are similarly
surprised i think
but the other big thing has been just
the epic dysfunction out of dc
really really shameful uh and
you know like i at some point was like
look nancy should take this deal because
it's going to be one of the only ways to
get help to people before the end of the
year
uh and i think it's pretty objectively
reasonable you know it's like
you'd rather get help sooner than later
i mean people are freaking suffering
like restaurants and small businesses
are closing right left
uh and here we are lame duck session
like is it gonna happen
it's it's doubtful uh and
a lot of people are just like well it's
freaking mitch mcconnell's fault
um to which i largely agree like mitch
mcconnell should be approving
legislation that that it gets out the
door
um but i i think you have to take some
responsibility
if you're the democrats too because
you're looking at it saying okay
like like what is the offer on the table
like you know what can i work with what
what can i not work with
uh there comes a point when uh doing
something is better than doing nothing
and uh and so that that's another like i
have been staggered by the
the level of uh
catastrophic dysfunction out of dc uh
it's been very very
heartbreaking uh uh like
saddening uh you name it i mean i i
think about it a lot
um and this is a time when it'd be tough
if we did everything right
you know if we had a government that had
a chit together and was like going
around like abc and the rest of it
and a would be hey we should send you
all money like other governments are
doing it canada is doing it
but you know it's like the odds of you
actually
one trusting the public in the
government and
acting accordingly and then two not
feeling like you have to go out and do
that uber shift
or do something that's kind of
discretionary
to make ends meet like go way up if i
sent you money
like it does not make that much sense
for me to think that you're going to
comply and shut down if you're like a
bar owner if you're a bar owner you're
like trying to
dig yourself out of like this deep dark
like well of red ink and then i come and
say hey
um shut down um you know you'll be like
i
i you know it's like and i don't send
you money
then you'll be like wait a minute like
what what are you talking about you know
like that like i need to employ people
like
i've run i've run a business a small
business um
and like you feel very very deeply
responsible for your staff
uh you know and it's impossible to pay
your staff unless you operate
and so like if you're told not to
operate you're looking at it being like
you know and then there's like a human
reaction again if you send
people money they're much much more
likely
to adhere to public health guidelines
to have like a sense of the future
and doing one without the other does not
make that much sense to me
i think most other countries made the
same conclusion but our
government is not up for the challenge
here
and and it makes me sad how a lot of the
commentary just revolves around
essentially it is the other
guy's fault it's the other team's fault
and again there's enough fault to go
around but you know like
at some point um
at some point someone has to govern and
it it makes me very very sad that
um that anyone who wanted to
think of the worst of dc is
having their point of view confirmed
every single day
you know like one of the things i almost
tweeted that i have not but maybe i
should
is that if you give washington an excuse
not to work
it will take it um because it turns out
them not working
really doesn't hurt them very much you
know i mean like they still have
reelection rates of 90 plus like they're
still chilling
uh it's one reason why my backdrop is
what it is like i'm here in georgia
um because we have to try and remove
excuses
for dc not to work you know like if you
actually
give it uh give democrats a chance where
it's like well it's not mitch mcconnell
saying no no no to everything it's like
well then
the the odds of a relief bill getting
passed would shoot up i presume
uh and so you know i'm here trying to
help make that happen
you know then there's this also argument
i agree evan you said to thank you
there's this other argument it's like
well we don't have to pay people they
don't need a relief bill if he just
opened up the economy right like start
shutting things down just let's just
navigate this only a small percentage of
people getting coveted
and what i think is so wrong is that
even if you did open up the economy like
no like nothing held back you like talk
to restaurant owners they're not at a
hundred percent capacity
talk to restaurant owners in the south
where it's all open they're like
very very low yeah uh you know and
that's because
it's like disney world reopened and like
did they have like
you know throngs of people like flocking
to go there no
so like so because guess what like there
are a certain number of people that are
just going to look up and say
is kovid still out there yes like hey
maybe i'll stay home
no yeah it's like i mean i brought my
family here to georgia
uh and uh the
airport was pretty empty you know so on
on the one hand
uh you're like well good for me
in the sense that uh you know like your
risk level feels lower but then you're
like
the level of ambient economic activity
is very low and that's not because of
government and force shutdowns that's
because
of millions of americans just making an
individual determination
that that that trip to disney world is
not worth it right now
right the and it's one of the reasons
like you and i were
pretty bummed like our plan was just
bring a whole bunch of people to georgia
and knock on doors and do all these
things and look
not only is kovit still real but it's
it's growing um and we can't do that but
we can't bring
sadly like thousands of yangyang you
know yang speaks listeners to come
volunteer in georgia because it's
horrible that's how you spread the virus
um
and it breaks my heart and we had a lot
of ambitious plans um but like sadly we
have to pump the brakes a bit you know
and it makes sense no i'm genuinely
torn on this zach because um
i saw that maybe a thousand republican
operatives are descending on the state
uh yeah and um
32 million dollars in in funding on that
side
um and so you want to be smart i
genuinely think that you could uh
campaign in a way that does not truly
elevate the coveted risk
you know like if you're walking around
outside you have a mask on
um and you interact with folks like i
don't think the risk is really
uh being increased by your presence
um and so like if you can imagine
someone who lived in like
you know let's say north carolina they'd
drive x hours to
come through here and then they do some
uh
some campaigning in a way that's
responsible like i i truly don't think
that actually elevates
um elevates the risk uh
at least you know it doesn't elevate the
risk in a way that
timmy would foreclose the activity uh
and and there are folks that are are
like-minded to me so i should have some
fun people um
spending time uh spending time on the
ground here in georgia it should be fun
both of them inside and outside of state
i mean we've got a lot of work to do
inside the state
i've got events uh with like uh high
school democrats group uh college
democrats group
uh asian american community the wnba
martin luther king iii like you know
like all sorts of fun stuff coming
good work um uh so i i'm i'm of two
minds about it
genuinely it's like uh like i think
you'd wanna temper any activities you
have here so that they're
responsible and safe you don't wanna you
know just like have a mosh pit or
something
but if you come in like you're wearing a
mask and you're uh
you know trying to register voters
that's happening all the time right now
it'd be optimal obviously if like people
got themselves tested and did things
where they're like okay like i'm sure
i'm not
spreading anything um but but i think
that
this is an all hands on deck situation
uh and
i think that at least one side is going
to be treating it that way yeah
[Music]
thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this episode of yang speaks
skillshare is this awesome online
learning community
where people go to learn from experts
in creative fields they
gain new skills you can really get lost
in your own creative learning i'm
looking at a class called plants
at home uplift your spirit and your
space by the scandinavian christopher
griffin
because there's a certain element of
plants in a home that
actually help and that sounds stupid it
sounds like very like
mom or karen or whatever but like live
laugh love but for real
that totally works we're not that far
removed from uh
you know just running around in the
woods yeah well it's helpful because me
i just like buy an ikea plant
and like there's actually a little more
art to that so i'm learning about
various versions of succulents and
whatever the heck that you know i i bet
the ladies love that too you go in
they're like ooh this guy's sensitive
oh yeah good point i water that yeah if
you water that you know what that says
that says responsibility that's what
that says
so if you too want to figure out how to
make your place greener and a million
other potential avenues
for learning and creativity
exploreskillshare.com
yang speaks the first 1000 people to use
our link will get a free trial
of skillshare's premium membership
receive free access to thousands of
classes for a limited time
be one of the first 1000 to sign up at
skillshare.com
yang speaks so most classes are under 60
minutes with short lessons they fit in
your schedule you do it easily
there's no ads they're always launching
new premium classes and it's less than
10
a month with an annual subscription so
it's cheap it's awesome
it's effective so break up your team
with kind of spontaneous acts of
creativity
go to skillshare.com yang speaks check
it out
so we hit as of yesterday which is
yesterday was november 19th
when we're recording this uh 187 000 new
cases which is essentially a record
uh if you look at the graph of cases
it's a tidal wave it's
an exponential increase thoughts on
you've got thanksgiving
normally um this upcoming wednesday is
the busiest travel day of the year
suggestions for people traveling for
thanksgiving i think somebody's cut like
some of the curfews or you know things
like that are getting ridiculous but
thoughts on how people handle their
travel
and um holiday season this year
i can speak for myself i mean our plan
was to have family members over
uh and most of them were within like a
driving distance most of them are very
safe
uh and the rest of it uh and so we
didn't have a problem with that
uh you know like that that would have
been a fine plan
here in georgia some people invited us
over um for
like a socially distanced dinner it's
very nice of them um
and it would again just be a drive so as
long as you're not
interacting heavily with folks in uh in
an indoor environment
um on the way there and you're
comfortable with the people that you're
going to be seeing
and maybe even socially distance
throughout like i think that's a fine
way to go
okay yeah we're doing the same thing we
we have
like a small family gathering but
everybody's been quarantined and things
like that uh look i do encourage people
to be safe
uh covert is serious um and now again
just
just don't go to that thanksgiving rave
you know don't go to like that
but
but you know i think like getting
together with family and extended family
um you know who who who you're um
in contact with somewhat periodically
like it's on
like particularly they're not high risk
like i wouldn't recommend
um visiting your elderly parents
necessarily but you know like that
that's not a good idea
at any point during this during this
virus
so the last thing i think i want to ask
andrew is that like we it kind of gets
brushed on the rug with all the election
nonsense but we we have a vaccine now
we've been able to talk about it we've
two
it looks like two vaccines moderna and
pfizer both seem to have
uh 95 effective uh
covid vaccines which to me is like i
love
i've always been a capitalist like pro
capitalist in my opinion like america is
like
hyper thank you science yeah we came up
with like like science gear just for the
occasion
science cap science mask i don't know if
i wish i had one i could put it on right
now
uh but go science and and this one thank
you madarina and pfizer
yeah i'll never say anything mean about
you again pharma i'm kidding
you guys uh i'm kidding they're they're
problems
[Laughter]
do you like uh
you've said this before on other things
um
i think we should make the politicians
try it on their own families
um before before it goes out which i
know is like kind of weird like
politicians get it first but there's a
lot of mistrust
in the system right now in our world
like thoughts on how you would roll this
out effectively
i think having trusted public figures
make use of the vaccine is a good idea
um you know like if the science um
checks out i would do it uh yeah you
know i mean the thought process
is like you know look everyone's gonna
get this thing eventually anyway you
might as well get this show on the road
and do it in a way that
uh augments adoption um there was an
idea out of freakonomics
our friends of economics stephen dubner
which i think was a really good one is
we just have a freaking lottery
where like every day someone who gets
the vaccine is gonna get a hundred
thousand dollars
and just like publicize that winner i
just like pay like
you know i mean it it would be a trivial
cost to increase adoption
um because if you gave a hundred
thousand a day like what what does that
amount to
like 36 million dollars over the year
that's like a penny
compared to the cost of getting adoption
up not vaccination
um and reviving it so maybe a hundred
thousands too
um too conservative maybe we should go
with like a million a day
you know like like 365 million dollars
would still be worth it
uh so i think that's a yeah and then
just publicize it it's like the the
vaccine
you know winner of the day is like this
person and being like i never thought
i'd win you know just freaking publish
that thing every single day
uh that's the kind of thing we should do
to increase adoption that would actually
work better than me getting it
yeah that's true because people don't
trust politicians anyway um that would
be fun yeah
anybody if you you know yeah
it could be like you get 500 bucks you
get 20 000 bucks like this freaking go
bananas
don't you guys love how andrew yang's
answers to a lot of things revolves
around giving people money
like you know does that not work out a
whole host of problems
uh i'm into it man i'm actually into
actually just paying people directly to
take the vaccine too
um also a great idea
wait wait wait wait let's do some math
on this hang on hang on let's say let's
say you
need 330 million people vaccinated like
10 bucks like 3.3 billion
um again trivial in the in the
context of trying to resuscitate a 22
trillion dollar economy
um you get a vaccine we'll give you 10
bucks on a lollipop you know you had a
kid like
a kid with you i want to make sure we
quickly talk about humanity forward to
um on a lot of stuff we're doing on cash
relief because
um we look we've looked at this left
right and sideways
you know every direction and
the only way we get anything done in
congress is by actually building that
network in congress and talking to them
our elected officials and convincing
them that cash relief is the only way
forward to get us out of this pandemic
and it's not a hard argument
but it takes time and money oh i do this
every day you know the zack i talked to
um on average at least one maybe closer
to two or three members of congress on
any given day
um saying hey you know what would be
great cash relief
and a lot of them are into it um so
we have to just keep pushing because the
people know it's right
a lot of legislators you get get them
one-on-one they know what's right too
so we just need to make it safe for them
all to move forward and act
so we're trying to build a caucus on
capitol hill
and we could really use some resources
to do so it's like the people's lobbyist
uh where i had a video where it's like
we're gonna
raise money for this effort and then
pelt members on the head with the money
but the truth is that politicians
respond to financial resources because
they know that they're going to be up
for re-election in two years or what not
and if someone gets behind them let's
say the yang gang
let you know let's say like a group
that's like one to two million strong
depending upon
like how you're counting it then members
of congress could look up and say oh
like this could actually make my race
easier
and it's also the right thing to do um
and then if the organization has money
behind it
uh then they're like ooh like you know
this
group might actually put resources into
my race like when i run for reelection
if i
am pro cash relief like they could
actually help defend me
that's the kind of thing that tips
legislators uh
over the finish line so we just need to
raise enough money where they can see
that we have a professional lobbying org
with a bank role that can actually help
get them reelected i mean that that's
like the
frankly like the the crass reality of it
all uh so we are raising money
for this effort again the people's
lobbyists uh
and we are punching way above our weight
class already because everyone regards
the yang yang
as uh this awesome cool vital new force
in
politics uh they're like me they're a
little terrified of the yang gang too if
they mess up
love you guys and and so
so we need to take advantage of this and
the biggest way um
so you've probably seen we have a
national
advocacy campaign that we're raising
money for that is essentially this
lobbying campaign
um and it's a phenomenal investment in
the sense that
uh we can increase the odds of cash
leave getting out there so if you give
10 bucks
you know like we might be able to help
increase the chances of you getting
uh a lot more out of congress uh that
might otherwise be the case
yep it is it's going to research it's
going to
experts on the hill it's going to
organizing and it's going to advertising
it's like the big four
uh it's pretty standard um but we'll do
it in very
andre yang's style where it's out of the
box effective high roi
um the same way a good builder should
let's do it let's go fight it out on
capitol hill
and i'm excited about it because i've
been having these conversations with
members and and a lot of them are
receptive and responsive so if we if we
have the reasons
and we're not not yet allowed to talk
about who's committed but it's um
who no we can't tell but if if you're
interested in donating it's uh it's
movehumanityforward.com
um you click the donate button um it's
all going to cash relief right now
um advocacy lobbying uh
efforts to get this done people already
probably know that like we've given
almost 10 million dollars directly to
families so you know we believe
um but like i think that this is another
very effective way to try and unlock
cash for people uh you know the needs
are so great
um like i see this as like uh we'll
spend
a million to maybe unlock tens of
billions
you know what i mean it's like a very
high leverage move it's it's there too i
mean the stock market's pricing in
that there's going to be a stimulus bill
of 1 trillion dollars so the question is
eventually when god willing congress
does something um so
the question is what's the composition
of the trillion you know what i mean
like
right now you know that trillion is
probably going to get tilted very much
towards institutions
uh if you tilt it more towards people
that's a
potential value of hundreds of billions
of dollars for
people families communities amen and you
know
that's what i'm chasing one of my
favorite quotes like the only thing
necessary for evil to prevail is for
good people to do nothing
and andrew and i you and i we've been
we've been to the top of the political
mountain if you will we've met the
leaders we've met the help we've met the
people that are supposed to be saving us
and i promise you
the cavalry's not coming this is it like
you're this is the coalition of the good
people trying to do something and this
is us
and it it's terrifying but this is how
anything gets done
and so we we our ass is you know help us
do good um that's what we're doing uh
help us be the good people
um and let us be the cavalry because
it's not coming it's just us
so um moviemaniaforward.com
we're doing some cash relief we're gonna
be doing a while we'll keep you updated
on the show
and with that let's go to ariana picari
and talk about
all the problems in our media and you
can go on for days on this andrew uh but
tune in guys it's good
you know what yang speaks we are all
about our data being
ours and one way you can protect your
data is by using expressvpn
what's a what's expressvpn vpn stands
for virtual private network
when you beam into the internet using a
server far
far away and no one knows it's you big
companies use it
spies i assume use it cool people who
don't want anyone
selling and reselling their data use it
and you can use it too
it's fast it's easy expressvpn is the
number one rated vpn by wired
verge c net uh and yang speaks i gotta
say
that you know we looked at the field and
said these guys have it
there's another perk too is that you can
access content that's
only available in europe
or whatever other country it is like
that
european exclusive content you could be
like beat me to europe
i'm gonna watch people talk in french
so go to expressvpn.comyang to get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free expressvpn.com
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks
the public editor the columbia
journalism review
and former msnbc producer ariana picari
ariana welcome thank you so much for
having me
well thank you i'm a huge admirer as i
know many people are because you did
something that dozens of people
imagined doing millions of people are
wondering why
more of it doesn't go on but you
actually resigned from an msnbc producer
role
because you were concerned about the
nature of broadcast journalism in terms
of
fulfilling its function in uh edifying
that the public
and i want to start all this out by
saying that um you identify issues that
are um germane to any broadcast media
news outlet that this isn't like uh
you know some kind of msnbc is like
singular
um and despite the fact that i'm on air
on cnn
like i 100 agree with you that these
issues are
endemic to essentially the medium and
it's not just an msnbc thing
so many americans right now are
concerned that we are
more polarized than ever and i think a
huge part of that
in people's minds is that the media
is not helping the media is not really
bringing us together around a common set
of facts
but instead is uh kind of separating us
into camps for sure
and i um that was one of my big concerns
when i
when i was at msnbc um i definitely saw
and
um the polarization um
i was living it in real time and i could
see how it affected my family at home in
virginia
um right away and it's it's weird i felt
like the polarization was almost having
um it was
it was having kind of a counter uh
productive
effect in some ways for for msnbc but
yeah i definitely can i call it you know
i some ways call it the gerrymandering
of the media you know and
everyone on the left kind of keeps
getting
pushed further and further to left and
on the right they keep getting pushed
further further to the right
and really it's driven largely
not entirely not wholly but largely um
by you know the financial incentives um
that are required you know they gen up
their audiences
and um so you know it's being done for
profit
and by and very few people are actually
benefiting
um so yeah my concerns are are
definitely
you know for the democracy
um at large and it plays out in many
ways
yeah so so you started out in a
different environment in
public radio uh and so
how was that experience for you i guess
that was relatively early in your career
yeah i started i you know right after
college i
had a crisis of identity and i didn't
know what i was going to do so i started
off first and
and working as a financial advisor for
for morgan stanley dean witter
and um it was actually kind of during
that miserable commute around the dc
beltway
i discovered public radio and over a
number of years i
kind of set my sights on public radio
because i realized that's really what i
wanted to be doing i just loved the
craft of it and i loved this the
way that they told stories i'd never had
a desire to go into tv
and um i also didn't really do
internships through college because i
was you know working full-time and just
a little bit lost in general so it
wasn't until after a while after college
i
discovered npr and set my sights and
i started at npr in 2002
and um loved every day from from the
you know first minute i was there so so
you were attracted to npr and i have to
say when i was out there
campaigning around the country npr was
like its own oasis
of news like there were folks that
listened to it uh
the local npr stations
uh seemed very free they were very pure
you'd go in
and they had listeners who really wanted
a particular
version of both the news and the
listening experience
uh you were attracted to that and it
sounds like you were there from 2002 to
2013
more or less i mean you were doing some
other stuff but it was all
uh public radio directed is that right
it's like 11 years or so
yes that's correct yeah um and
yeah i mean i just this morning i was
listening i you know i listened
to kqed frequently which is the san
francisco station and
you know it's it's such a you know
pleasure because the you know the local
public affairs program forum they were
they covered
um the local drug overdose epidemic
and how it's gotten worse through the
pandemic and then they moved on to
the the new covid vaccines for another
30 minutes and it's this long
in-depth conversation and things that i
didn't even know i needed to know but
yeah i mean it's it's it's just so much
more and so
such better information that you can get
yeah and npr is supported
through public funding though npr now
has
so many listeners and sponsors and
advertisers that
it's largely self-sustaining and a lot
of people have also donated to it
so it's like a combination um
and then you wound up at msnbc which
uh it seemed like your
experience was a bit different uh how
was the experience
i kind of came into it with the attitude
i mean we knew that
everything was kind of you know we knew
that ratings i knew that ratings
um played a part in in our daily lives
um i didn't understand the extent of it
and
i thought coming in i could bring
my skills that i had in public radio and
part of that
is really trying to find new and
interesting and compelling stories and
angles and voices
and they would want to you know they
would be they would welcome that because
uh in my mind i felt like one of my big
criticisms of cable news coming into it
was the repetition it was just i just
felt like it was
you know you're watching the same five
or six stories kind of
all day throughout the day so um
i thought that that was an opportunity
for me to come in and
you know make things better right um so
i
i struggled with that for a few years
um i really i you know i tried different
types of stories and kind of i
strengthened my pitches
and realized okay they might not listen
to me the first time but i'll keep
coming back and you know trying to
to sell this other idea or strengthen my
argument maybe they don't
you know maybe it's not intuitive why
something um is a good idea
and over time i you know i i
got a little bit frustrated but um then
started to get
at the same time a little bit of
seniority so i was more involved in the
planning meetings you know with the
senior producer
and the executive producer and or the
senior producers are
there's usually more than one and at
that point i
realized the extent that they really
that the ratings really drove all of the
decisions
and it was it was it's down to you know
it's the first thing out of their mouths
as soon as you throw out an idea and
they don't necessarily talk that way in
the wider
editorial meetings with the full staff
it really was
in the smaller planning meetings you
know it's the first thing out of their
mouths like how things rated the night
before how
they thought something did and those
those ratings are broken down by quarter
hours so they have a pretty good
understanding of what did well and what
didn't do well
and so they will track the topics of
course
and they'll track the guests you know so
if you know it's the if the guest does
well or if progress
guest rates well or not they really
rely on that um for
almost every decision so um it
that's it wasn't until the last few
years
when i uh the reality um became
you know pretty stark to me and then you
know i wasn't gonna be able to fight
that fight
you know there wasn't you know these
people are just doing their jobs
and it's all out of their hands it's out
of lawrence's hands it's out of phil
griffin's hands
it's it's at a higher way higher pay
level um
where the problems are you know one of
the things you said was that look these
are good people
you know trying to do good work but
they're put in a position where their
job does not necessarily produce the
kind of journalism you'd want it to
which is something i completely uh get
and empathize with is that if you put
people in a position where their
incentives are all steering them one
direction you kind of expect them to
end up uh listening to those incentives
you know it's like
and if you don't listen to those
incentives and let's say your ratings
underperform
consistently then someone's going to
make a change and so like that's the
the race you're always running
like were there other people that ever
expressed any misgiving maybe someone
else from like a similar background
as you yes
um those conversations didn't happen
very often
but over the last year or two when i was
there there were times when i would have
conversations in private with other
producers and
um certainly they you know
with a couple of people um
they said i think we're making things
worse
you know some seem to think that
yeah what we're doing here is probably
benefiting trump and would help him get
elected again
the person who said we are a cancer that
is that's one of those conversations it
was somebody
in the building um uh
and has been in the the business a long
time so
um but it wasn't something that people
talked about in the open
you know it wasn't until i went in and
sat down like kind of one-on-one with
them
um otherwise that the comp the the
notion that ratings drive everything
it's just
it's really built into the process and
it's it's
of course you know that's just that's
just what you do and you know most of
those people
came up through the commercial tv system
somehow and
i obviously have a public radio
background and none of the editorial
decisions i ever made before were based
on
how it would rate or how big of an
audience we thought we would have i mean
we always wanted a big audience but you
know you hope that you know what you're
doing is compelling enough to hold
people's attention um but that's not
what
determines those decisions and so for me
you know it was like it really raped
against my
nerves every time i heard them say
something like you know that's not going
to rain
when it's something that i knew would be
a good topic some of the decisions were
made out of ideological
reasons um but it also
kind of drives the division that that
we're seeing and the polarization
in this in the country so they might be
pumping up you know
um ideas that are exciting to some
people but then there
was never you know they don't get
excited about the you know someone with
a more nuanced or moderate
take on things and um
so that that just kind of keeps driving
everybody apart and there's you know
you know there's no sense that okay
there is some benefit to compromise
every now and then i just i know that
that's not a popular idea right now
because we've gotten so far away from
that but
um you know the the in my sense is
that it just when you
stand back and look at the totality of
you know all the
different ways that the financial
incentives affect the content
it's just driving us down the wrong path
and it's only getting worse
the way that i see it
[Music]
[Applause]
all right it's almost december you
haven't bought
anyone a gift but if you're looking
for a gift that they're gonna love we
recommend raycon
wireless earbuds these things are
awesome they work
they're comfortable they cancel out
noise mine are blue and they look badass
this is why i love them um i felt cooler
when i put them on
um a little like back like felt
futuristic if you will
uh and they work just as well like they
work just as good
as they look if that makes any sense
like that you're not compromising
quality for all that style
they are the smart buy in that they're
just as cool and high quality as those
other things but they don't break the
bank like those other things so go to
buy raycon dot com slash yang today to
get twenty percent
off your recon order this offer is
available for a limited time only you
don't wanna miss it
you can get this stuff for the holidays
for your favorite someone and they will
love you for it
trust us on that i love mine zach loves
his
that's by recon dot com slash yang to
get twenty percent off your recons by
raycon.com
you drew a couple of examples in your
resignation letter which
i recommend that everyone find and read
because i just thought it was so brave
and incisive and true
so thank you for it and i'm a huge
admirer of yours you did something
at a principle that the vast vast
majority of people
don't ever do uh and if enough people
did what you did we might actually have
a chance and i don't mean just in media
though the media is
a significant part of this but you know
in in many different
environments where your financial
incentives are to
uh just pretend it's okay um and
a lot of us can sense that it's not okay
so two of the things that you pointed
out as
uh programming choices one was that
anything with donald trump
or response to donald trump rated better
and so
uh you or just everybody every cable
news
outlet covered everything trump did um
during his 2016 run and then that became
true obviously when he was president
and then the inverse of that was that if
there was something kind of educational
or scientific
or deeper then it would be less
appealing or wouldn't rate as well and
so you want to
wound up with like a bias towards trump
all the time
and less about for example what a public
health
official or scientist was saying yeah
yeah
um and initially when the
pandemic started they
are professional journalists and they
kicked into gear just like they should
and they were
trying to get the information they could
from scientists and doctors
and front line workers and
developed a special
dr zeke emanuel was you know on once a
week
um to cover you know focus on issues
related to covid
and after a number of weeks they
discovered that that wasn't rating well
so
then it got kind of you know started on
monday tuesday and they pushed it to a
friday
because that's a day that they don't
care as much about ratings because
that's
um for our own program for
msnbc's or last words and programming
needs that it wasn't
um as important and then it slowly just
kind of fizzled out and died
and it was because it wasn't raiding
well and
and then you could see the coverage when
they were
would do a coveted segment it really was
about just the politics
um and they would have on science
reporters or correspondents
but they were you know pushing them
trying to get them to talk more about
the politics and the actual science and
it was through a time when there were a
lot you know there i mean there's still
lots of information coming out all the
time about the
about the the virus and vaccines and
what we know and what we don't know
and that all of that was
you know they would try to get to it if
they could or
it just wasn't kind of the top line it
was something that was thrown in maybe
as a you know an afterthought
um the all of that information really
got pushed to the wayside and
they focused much more on the politics
and it was you know the
uh trump attacking the blue state
governors
or you know what trump you know what
dumb thing trump said or didn't say or
didn't do
um it really focused on that and i i
understand there's a time and a place
for that but it was just dominated
everything that drove me crazy on the
trail too
where it was always like trump's stupid
or inflammatory comment of the day and
then even
like i'd be running for president in
iowa new hampshire and they'd be like
trump said this what do you think of
that and i'm just like are you kidding
me
really yeah and yeah yeah that
um that same idea was pervasive
throughout the end
you know it was the last election cycle
as well um
the democratic primary process you know
if there was a personality
dispute that got way more attention than
any interesting
policy conversation and i think there
were lots of interesting policy
conversations we could have had
you know the ideas that you had
being the start of it but then
you know when it came down to the
general and it was biden versus
trump and you know every almost every
single
i i know that they tried to to focus on
biden
when they could but it always turned
into a segment about trump
you know they don't want to talk about
anything that is negative towards
democrats because that was bad for the
msnbc audience
and the same thing you know applied to
the democratic primaries as well you
don't
there just wasn't a full discussion that
ultimately benefits
everyone so i think i might have
been part of that or non part of that
yeah i know i know this is not exactly
an unbiased
audience i'm talking to right now but
yeah no no i mean
again like this this to me is more of
like a systemic um
uh no it is for sure and it
uh yeah i saw it happen i watched it in
2016 and so that you know when everybody
was
i'm sorry um everyone was shocked that
hillary didn't do better than she did i
i was frustrated because i was like no
there were
there were polling numbers out that
showed you know enthusiasm for her
you know that were concerning and you
know
that msnbc wasn't covering that so that
liberal audience didn't
necessarily you know necessarily well
that's rough you know like that there
were actually some
numbers that cut the other way that
weren't covered i mean that that's
that's actually new to me
relatively speaking maybe everyone knows
that already i was
angry almost every day in those meetings
through and it it
did it was not pleasant because i
i was at a point where i i i mean i
never really bite my tongue anyway but i
i just could not believe that they were
making decisions about
you know economic poli segments and oh
that's not gonna
you might not the date i gave my
resignation they cancelled
an economic segment because quota wasn't
gonna rate and they filled it with some
other like
um you know not a serious
segment and um
[Music]
i you know between the pandemic
and i i frankly had issues with how they
were covering the george floyd stuff
um the protests uh
again you know
the way that they covered the protest
they they
wanted conflict and they put the
correspondence on the ground
in a way that they they even if nothing
was happening they wanted it to seem
like something was happening
and if there was a car that was on fire
they're gonna play that video
over and over again meanwhile 95
of the protests were peaceful but i've
been in the control room
going back to 2015 and and the black
lives matters protest then
people um they would monitor
all of those protests they'd have
cameras and choppers you know they're
monitoring the protests
and unless it turned violent they would
not quote take it live
you know they they wouldn't show that
peaceful protest because nothing was
happening
according to them you know it was it was
boring and it wouldn't make good tv
so that um that is the type of thing
that
kind of got to me um through the george
floyd
floyd's
coverage there were there were other
elements there were there were
points about the election and
election security those stories kept
getting
sidelined they were not covering them
they'd
you know i i was trying to get them to
cover the issues you know how were you
gonna have a safe election
you know with covid and you know there
were lots of groups working on it
they um uh it was really really really
difficult to get them
to cover that um
there was
there were opportunities when trump went
to tulsa
there were opportunities to to talk
about some of the
kind of painful history in this country
um
it was would have been very easy to
discuss
um the history in tulsa and the tulsa
riots or
juneteenth and what is all be
you know what is behind that and why
it's so meaningful to the
african-american community
and you can trace the anger from those
events
to george floyd it would have been it
wouldn't have taken very long at all
but there were there was there was um a
history there that i didn't know
and i know a lot of smart people and
journalists didn't know
and it was a perfect opportunity to to
share that and it helps
the nation understand you know what is
happening other than just
you know people are angry and and
looting the local walmarts
one thing that a producer a friend of
yours said that really
um seemed telling was look people come
to us for comfort like they don't see us
as the news
i i thought that was incredible and and
there is something fundamental about
two different purposes one would be i'm
going to edify and inform
and so i'm going to serve you some stuff
that might be
not that scintillating it might be kind
of boring it's like broccoli as
programming
and then there's this other direction
that it's like i'm entertainment
like i'm going to have a certain patter
and rhythm and characters and something
that you can cheer or boo
right yeah and that was in one of our uh
planning meetings so that was a senior
producer and um
it's definitely something that you know
stood out and something i remembered
because
you're abdicating your role as a
journalist and that's it's confusing
because
otherwise it kind of looks like a
newscast you know you have an anchor
sitting at a desk
with you know you know the tv over his
shoulder
and you're covering things that are in
the news
and so the audience uh you know i
realized that you know they
there's there's an awareness that msnbc
is um
uh more opinionated than the straight
you know 6 p.m newscast but at the same
time
they're they they play it both ways
so that's what i think is really
dangerous when it
looks like something that should be
reliable but
it it isn't really then that's that's to
me
where the problem comes in i'm pretty
sure news is in the name somewhere
you know like there's somewhere in there
like there's the word news
um so so you have these concerns they're
building up over a period of time
um and then you actually had to bite the
bullet and say wait a minute am i going
to keep doing this or am i going to
leave
and when you did decide to leave again i
thought it was so courageous because
you weren't sure what the next step was
it wasn't one of these situations where
you were like oh i'm gonna
find my time and then get some kind of
sweet uh job offer and this other thing
and then i'll
um you know write my letter uh so what
was it that
actually uh pushed you to action because
again i'm sure that there are
dozens or hundreds of people in media
who've at least reflected for a moment
on the concerns you're describing but
they did not do what you did
um well i first want to say i don't
blame
most of the people in the industry for
for not just picking up and quitting
their jobs because the industry isn't a
crisis i mean
the last several years they've done
relatively well but
um yeah i don't blame anyone either fyi
um when you where where are you gonna go
what are you gonna do like you know
if if you're if you wanna stay in
some element of the news business then
there really aren't a lot of other
places to go
and if you have a family and a mortgage
you know dependent
it's it's a really hard choice to make
so i don't i don't point fingers at them
but
i got to a point where i um i had been
contemplating leaving for a couple of
years
i wasn't you know i didn't know exactly
what i was going to do
i had not pursued other jobs
aggressively because i knew
i was probably going to want to work on
this
issue some way somehow and probably come
out
when i posted my resignation letter i
thought i would i was just kind of
putting that
down as like a marker in the sand to say
this is you know where i draw the
line and i'm moving on and i thought
that you know maybe a handful of people
would
would respond to it at the time i
thought it was going to get lost to the
internet
but i was going to use that just as like
you know moving forward you know
i quit the industry and this is why i
didn't expect the reaction that i did
but i um
it it really was kind of all together i
just couldn't you know i again we're
we're in the middle of a pandemic
and um uh i
you know not a great time economically
to to quit one's job you know because it
was a you know it was a
good job and with benefits and um
you know now i don't have any of that
but i have not regretted
it for one second um it's i don't have
that angry feeling in me every day when
i wake up
so wow i mean yeah that's profound
so you post this resignation letter you
think well a few industry types will see
it but it'll just get lost the internet
and you said that you weren't expecting
the reaction
that it got um what was that reaction i
mean i certainly know that i saw it and
said like wow this person's awesome i
need to reach out
uh but like what uh but i don't know
what you experienced at that point um
so yeah like what happened next well it
was interesting
you know um one of the first outlets
that picked it up
was fox news and they
they helped prove my point for me by
saying you know
msnbc producer
writes scathing letter about um the
divisive nature of her net network
you know and and without they took out
all of the context which is what they do
you know and it's something that kind of
drives up know that their audience and
um uh and for for clicks you know to
take to
to get each side loves it when they can
point out that the other side is somehow
you know absolutely bad or wrong um
so i got a lot of response
um i got thousands of uh
notes and you know whether it's it was
through my personal website which until
then had you know like
you know maybe two visitors um um the
the piece itself has been read over 300
000 times
on the actual website but then there was
like there was lots of coverage
elsewhere
and um people wrote to me on
twitter facebook uh instagram
and through my website i have thousands
of notes from people
across the spectrum you know certainly
a lot of people um on the right who read
the fox piece
you know they were you know cheering me
on i think they think
i might be something
different but um um
people on the left also and former
producers in the industry
and academics and presidential
candidates
yes yes they were like you know but
there were there was a sense that like
thank you like
we know that something is wrong and a
lot of people they're like
you know we don't know why it's gotten
so as bad as it is and this helps
explain that
um and you know some people will say you
know what are you naive like to think
that
ratings don't drive you know the news
business or
corporate media or whatever and my
reaction to that is what are you naive
to think it's not
doing damage to our lives every day you
know um
so but and i just got like it was
really heartwarming the um
across the spectrum i got really
thoughtful
kind notes thanking me for for what i
did
i thank you everyone should be thanking
you ariana
because we all can sense uh that
something is going wrong
and you you were one of the only brave
souls who came out from within one of
these organizations and said yeah
you're not imagining it it actually is
going wrong and it's
not good for any of us the country the
democracy our states of mind
um well uh i thank my mom
for like giving me a place to live in
the meantime so i
i don't crank through my savings too
much but
um i i was in a position where i i felt
like
it was a you know it wasn't an easy
decision but it was a relatively easy
decision
um given the state of things so
[Music]
how does andrew yang look so good it's
not easy
uh but part of it is wearing awesome
gear
i'm actually not that hip or anything
but i do enjoy
my clothes from outer known uh i'm
wearing a t-shirt right now
that they're comfortable they fit well
they're well made
and one thing that makes you feel good
about them is you know that they're made
in a way
that's good for the environment they
provide living wages to people so
like you feel conscientious it was
founded by pro surfer
and 11 time world champion kelly slater
it's got that vibe it's got kind of that
beachy surfer vibe
so if this sounds like something you
want to check out go to
outernow.com today and if you like the
clothes you can enter my code yang at
checkout and you get 25
off your first full price order wow
that's autonomous.com
o-u-t-e-r-k-n-o-w-n-dot-com
use my code yang at checkout for 25 off
check them out today i don't know.com
and don't forget promo code yang for 25
off i don't know if you ever watch the
office andrew but there's an episode
where michael scott
steve carrell uh puts on his jeans on
like casual friday
and he's like dancing around and putting
it like shaking his butt and putting it
in everybody's face because he's like so
happy and comfortable in his jeans that
is honestly
a version of what i do when i wear i
don't know jeans they're freaking
awesome they look good they feel good
uh so get that feeling get that warm
cozy feeling i don't known.com
promo code yang get your 25 off
[Applause]
so you get this outpouring of support uh
and now you
turn your attention to how can we solve
these problems and it was that
producer colleague of yours who said uh
in like
these forces are a cancer but if you can
cure the cancer then you can
uh heal the world so i'm sure that now
you've been
doing some deep digging and thinking as
to how we can fix this
you're now the public editor of the
columbia journalism review i think
you're reviewing cnn is that right what
does that job consist of anyway first
let's go there well it's you know once
every couple of weeks
um weighing in on something that i think
that you know something that i've
observed and they they wanted me to use
my experience
as a producer and so that's i mean it's
impossible for me not to watch it
without that eye
so um i
in general kind of i i can't help it and
i i i hope i don't have tunnel vision
but coming into
it i know the challenges of the job and
so i've wanted to
give them credit as well where i could
because
um i i just know it it is an incredibly
difficult job and the people are very
smart and they
want to do the right thing and you know
most of what they're doing is you know
news of some sort um
but i also know just i i know the
systemic issues
as i think well as
anyone would probably anyone you know
yeah and so i
i have tried to come at it from that
angle
with you know understanding and
compassion but like
dinging the overall structure of the
industry
so how do we fix this structure and i'm
just going to throw out a few
big ideas just because you know i think
these are kinds of things you might need
so one reason why npr seems so free and
glorious
is because its commercial incentives are
less
dominant where you know it's getting
money from
uh philanthropy or the feds or to some
extent sponsors
and you have uh the
corporation for public broadcasting the
cpb which uh also funds pbs
delightful pbs you know or like
you you kind of sense the difference
immediately when you hit one of these
um public channels because
it's it's kind of slower
softer more wholesome um
like less well-lit like like
the sets are worse uh uh one thing i
i sense about them too is like the
rhythm is different
and you talk about like the cable news
rhythm uh
there there's like a drum beat of
graphics and the rundown uh you know it
feels a little bit like a sports
highlight show
and then when you watch something on pbs
or npr
uh sometimes the conversations are
longer more drawn out
they're quote unquote like more boring i
guess or they're presented in a way
that's less flashy um for sure
so so number one would be trying to lift
the ratings pressure
in some way um i think that you know you
could
start introducing things that might help
one one thing i imagined which no one
would go for but
uh like i imagine a world where
essentially
um like an hour of advertising blocks is
like bought
by public funding and then you can
actually just do like an hour
block of stuff ad free uh
and you could just have a sit-down
conversation with an expert and just
like
do that and you know and like kind of
change the the rhythm of it
in a way that i think would be conducive
to something informative the third one
i'm going to throw out there which i
don't know how how
you would interpret this is to try and
revive the fairness doctrine from
1985 which was that if you were
broadcasting
something um issue related
then you have to cover both sides of the
issue
and that that was in place before fox
and msnbc came into being in i think the
mid-90s
so that that's another possibility i
don't know
if those ideas are things that you've
already weighed and some of them you
like some of them you don't like
um i will let's see here formatting you
know they basically
don't want to give any you know a person
more than like two minutes of talk time
um
per segment and uh obviously in public
radio and
pbs they will give more time and i think
that people
will stick with you if you're having a
deep meaningful conversation and they're
actually learning something because i
think humans are
inherently instinctually curious animals
and if they're learning something new
that they didn't know already then you
know they'll
keep watching but that's a um that's
another discussion
um in terms of what can be
done about the industry i have not
thought about the the
block advertising that's an interesting
idea
um i think there are things that can and
should be done on
on both sides i would love to see
public media um
enhanced and improved somehow and you
know i find myself
i mean i i agree with you i think npr
um is for me it's probably the most
reliable
and consistent and you know in terms of
um
getting news and information um pbs is
great but you get the news newshour for
one hour a day
and i would love to see a public affairs
channel
on the public side dedicated to public
affairs
and so that might mean multiple channels
for pbs
which would probably mean looking at a
different
funding structure and i'm curious about
a funding structure similar to the bbc
which is a licensing fee
which doesn't go through the
um political process
i would love i would love for us to
emulate the bbc
in a robust way i know it's not perfect
and they're having their own issues but
it's still leaps and bounds better than
what we're dealing with
and one thing that that frustrates me a
bit ariana is like here in the states
people like oh you can't have the state
involved with media because
you know or well totalitarianism and
you're like look
like the they've had the bbc for decades
and it seems to irritate everyone
equally uh we've had
pbs and npr and no one's like you know
accusing them
of of trying to create an authoritarian
state
you know it's like there's such like a
deep uh reflexive knee-jerk
reaction against uh the state having
anything to do with media that i find
not borne out by reality um
in other contexts with the bbc being one
prominent example
so who's reached out to you wants to
solve this problem ariana wants to crack
this nut like
because uh you know i'm i'm someone who
wants to try and fix this but and i
figure
i feel like right now you're one of the
most uh prominent invisible proponents
of media reform at this point
um i you know in the in in the number of
responses that i got when i posted my
resignation statement there were
a number of different types of people
and so there were people who
want to start their own um
new network of some sort or podcast
or a non-pro non-profit um
outlet and i will say like i
admire that and support all of that work
i but personally i think that there
needs to be some
network with critical mass so when you
have these
piecemeal options com popping up
it's all great work but i feel like it
gets lost and you know
the general public it doesn't reach them
necessarily like it should so i feel
like you need
a place with critical mass where people
know
and are familiar with and and can go to
it that's a whole other
other conversation but yeah i had um a
lot of people from the tech industry
reach out
um uh people that are
um you know either with foundations or
um support foundation you know had do
some work
with philanthropy they um i have been in
touch with
with um i've heard from
a number of people and i
am i'm trying to i i don't yeah i don't
know
what is going to make most sense i mean
it's kind of daunting i'm doing this
right now by myself
in a lot of ways so i i don't know you
are not alone ariana we are with you
there are so many people who are with
you this one let you know that yeah
thank you
um yeah yeah so i i i don't know if it's
if it's starting up a new organization
or teaming up with some with something
that's already
there i i've just kind of been at this
point talking to people being wanted
that you brought up the fairness
doctrine
that's one of the big questions i've had
is that something that we should re
consider
or something like it you know you know
there are you know it had
criticisms you know from both sides of
the spectrum you know conservatives
certainly maligned it but um uh
they were on the liberal side there were
people who had criticisms of the
fairness doctrine as well so it's like
you know
how do you create a standard for news
that you can that's enforceable um
and you know then you run into the
problem you know if you have to
give consideration to both sides of an
issue
then you run into the whole you know
false equivalency
problem and sometimes giving the other
side that is not
um it's not really the anti-climate
change doesn't really deserve it oh my
gosh
yes and that was like i struggled with
that in my years in public radio we
would do these discussions about climate
change and then you're
of course you would have you know 100
scientists who were
available and wanting to discuss climate
change and you're you were forced
to find someone on the opposite side and
it was really hard to find someone who
wasn't
funded by the petroleum industry but we
were we had to have that voice
and it was incredibly frustrating no
that would be frustrating i think at
some point
there should be like a 99 percent rule
where like
900 of scientists conclude something
that you
then you don't have to have that outlier
on
um so i agree with you there's a real um
there's a real consideration well there
are millions of americans that
want to join you as advocates for
better media that actually makes us
more informed and smarter and less
inflamed um
if someone wanted to lend you a hand
right now and it could be that there's
nothing that they can do but like
is there a way they can keep up with you
um or
say like you know i want to help support
ariana and
her current activism um
well i you know i have
my personal website which is not a great
website but um
i post my activities
there on the blog i'm working on getting
a new website
to to make that a little easier and a
little more efficient
um and i'm on twitter i have not started
any sort of an official organization so
if it's like
you know i don't have a gofundme site or
anything like that
i love your instincts ariana because i
can sense that you are
very much um an accidental activist
and an unwilling pundit shall we say in
the sense you know i mean like
like there are a lot of folks who'd be
trying to take this and milk it
no yeah i'm a shy person by nature so
you know doing anything that is not
you know behind the camera or behind the
microphone you know i uh
i i'm i'm hesitant to do it but i i feel
like it's so important that i
i do you're right i mean i i've been
kind of pushed into this
position so it is so important and i can
relate to a lot of it
um people don't believe this about me
but i actually
uh was happier to
not necessarily be the front man of the
band
[Laughter]
so i i got all better off stepped out
so oh thank you that's very kind it's
changing the discussion and you know it
might be
i don't know how you feel about it it
might be incremental but that's that's
how it's you know that's how it starts
yeah i'm i'm in a hurry uh
i know okay okay let's not be patient
there's too much at stake
yeah yeah well unfortunately because of
some of the things that you've outlined
uh so thoroughly and personally um we
don't have
limitless time like time's not really on
our side
uh and so you're you're going to be a
force for bringing us together i hope i
am too and please do consider me a
friend and partner and resource
because we need you to succeed we need
you to find a place where you can just
do what you do
you know there has to be a home for
producers who just want to produce good
news that actually
is what people need to hear as opposed
to what people
want to hear to be pissed off at the
other side in a moment
or you know or or they're going to get
to avoid things that don't
conform to their worldview i mean that's
not great and
we are in information silos right now um
but you're going to be a big part of the
solution i can sense it and also
you've you have a fan in me and many
others because you you did something so
rare in modern life which is you stood
up for your principles
and you did it for a genuine way like it
really wasn't like
some kind of um uh self-elevation or
anything like that you're just like look
here's here's who i am here's what i
think uh and
and now and i i can sense this too but
even your current approach
um so yeah we're gonna get to the bottom
of this ariana you and me
i like it i'm excited thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode